have you guys heard of the term sharing
no seriously sharing
about being a parent those parents that
share everything about their
children online
sharing things
[Music]
it's something that i do quite regularly
to be honest
people come to this country they haven't
been back they have kids that make their
life here
so i'm a family but i've never seen them
before if i didn't put them on social
media they wouldn't see them
sometimes i get really embarrassed my
mom posts stuff on
her facebook page or her instagram or
like
very embarrassing
they might not want their friends to see
them that way they want to have some
kind of control
over their image there's a famous case
of gwyneth paltrow posting a picture
of her daughter apple it was a selfie
there was nothing really you would think
contentious about it
yet her daughter complained about it
[Music]
in france kids can sue their parents for
sharing too much about them
wow i've been in trouble they're posting
about people who are not themselves
and that could impact us when we go out
into the real world and try to get a job
for example
there is an element of trust there
between a parent and child
not comfortable with my face being shown
without me knowing what
actually i'm being perceived as on their
platform
it may not seem like something which is
particularly significant it may be very
personally upsetting to
individuals what parents put on the
internet for people of our generation
your online identity isn't
so much seen as separate from your real
life identity but just
an extension of it social media profiles
are identity projects
i don't think that the government as
well as parents
should take control of our online
identity
because it is a part of who we are we
use our posts and stuff like that to
express ourselves
it draws attention to the kind of
complex everyday work that those posts
are doing
which are not about uh showing off
charanting isn't new
those of us that remember cringy moments
seeing kids photo albums handed around
to friends and family
you know knew all too well this is a
fairly fundamental urge on behalf of
parents to share
their pride about their children it's a
way of showing that you're doing that
parenting what is new about share and
think in the digital context
is of course that we are leaving a
fairly extensive and lengthy digital
stream
of photos comments stories
[Music]
we didn't want to invade her privacy
even though she's just a baby
that's going to stay online forever any
image you post now is going to be in the
internet forever
and then we don't know what's going to
happen in the future with things coming
up
like deep fake and you're just giving
your kids image away
[Music]
especially now with face recognition
software by posting facial images
online you're helping them create a
database you don't know how these images
that you've posted are going to be used
unfortunately we have
uh pedophile groups who will literally
scan videos to take out single
single shots which seem to expose you
know parts of the child's body or
and that you know that's a horrifying
thought so i think a lot of this is
about education
and and changing social norms one of the
strategies that i use
is taking pictures of them when they're
not actually facing the camera
so you can't see her face these new
digital tools enable us to
to look back on you know nice moments
from our child's early days early years
development etc
funny little things that you write on
there then it's like oh yeah that
happened then
over like a whole year ago it's pretty
good to let all
her friends know that i did this oh into
this school
and like knowing that oh i'm really
happy
if sharon thing is done in a responsible
way and it enables families to have
conversations for example with their
kids as they get older about
what you want to have online how you
portray yourself then actually i think
it can be a really important step
towards keeping kids themselves
safe as they become you know digitally
enabled adults
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video